en matière de nucléaire les vents est
passé d'une collaboration étroite avec
les états unis y en ait un
mec de la main à sa mine souterraine
nous prive d'un programme civil à l'arme
atomique
l'ambition nucléaire de l'iran a conduit
le pays à être isolés de la communauté
économique internationale depuis la
révolution de 1979
la politique de la république islamique
et les sanctions qui se sont abattues
sur l ont mise à mal le potentiel du
pays alors est il vraiment dans
l'intérêt de l'iran de posséder l'armé
atomique on vous explique
aujourd'hui on peut dire que l'iran est
capable technologiquement d'avoir la
production d'uranium enrichi en quantité
suffisante pour faire le beau gâteau qui
l'analyse de bernard hourcade géographe
spécialiste de l'iran et directeur de
recherche au cnrs est aujourd'hui
largement partagé voici selon le site
iron watch les principales installations
nucléaires présentes dans le pays au 31
mars 2021 réunies elles permettent aux
iraniens de disposer de tous les
éléments nécessaires à la production
d'électricité mais aussi sans doute à la
confection d'une bombe atomique yvan et
sur le seuil nucléaire defacto
technologiquement politiquement c'est
autre chose car même si la hausse du
prix du pétrole permet à l'iran de
connaître une croissance soutenue au
début des années 2000 la reprise de son
programme nucléaire militaire pendant sa
guerre avec l'irak lui a coûté cher en
août 2002 la découverte de deux sites
nucléaires inconnu en iran alarme la
communauté internationale qui fin 2006
décide de mettre en place des sanctions
économiques sans précédent pour
dissuader l'iran de continuer d'enrichir
son uranium
des sanctions qui vont se multiplier et
se durcir pendant presque dix ans
aujourd'hui la république islamique
d'iran est confronté en fait à toute une
série de difficultés économiques et
sociales il ya évidemment le poids des
sanctions qui empêche toute série
d'investissements de se réaliser qu'ils
empêchent également l'iran le pouvoir
exporter ses hydrocarbures
on est aussi dans une situation en fait
où la gestion économique est assez
difficile compliqué ça d'ailleurs été le
cas en fait depuis de très nombreuses
années en iran c'est un problème
structurel de gouvernance économique
pourtant après 12 ans de crise et 21
mois de négociations un accord est
conclu à vienne le 14 juillet 2015 entre
l'iran et les cinq membres permanents du
conseil de sécurité de l'onu plus
l'allemagne dans cet accord il est écrit
les sanctions adoptées par l'union
européenne et les etats unis en lien
avec le programme nucléaire iranien et
visant les secteurs des finances de
l'énergie et du transport seront levés
dès la mise en oeuvre par l'iran de ses
engagements nucléaires attestée par un
rapport de l'agencé internationale de
l'énergie atomique en janvier 2016 et en
échange d'une pleine coopération sur son
programme nucléaire l'iran fait son
retour sur le marché mondial on se
retrouve également dans une situation où
il ya une série de politiques
d'investissement des changes qui vont
être proposées alors par différents
partenaires internationaux d'haïti m
souviens bien après la signature de
l'accord il ya eu de nombreuses visites
réalisées à téhéran de la part de toute
une série de représentants politiques on
a aussi la perspective en fait qui
s'ouvre une nouvelle ère touristique il
ya eu d'ailleurs dans les mois qui ont
suivi dans la futuriste assez important
dans le pays alors après une contraction
économique d'environ 2% en 2015 la
croissance reprend et atteint 13 4 %
l'année suivante les exportations
iraniennes enregistre une progression de
30% et s'établissent à 84 milliards de
dollars une tendance qui s'explique
largement par la composition des ventes
iranienne formée aux deux tiers
d'hydrocarbures dans le même temps les
importations progressent de 20% à 63
milliards de dollars à ce moment l'iran
est aussi la deuxième économie de la
région du moyen orient et de l'afrique
du nord en termes de pib avec 412
milliards de dollars juste derrière
l'arabie saoudite
mais après deux années de reprise
économique le 8 mai 2018 il se passe
donald trump tient l'une de ses
promesses électorales et signe un
mémorandum pour retirer les états unis
de l'accord sur le nucléaire iranien
qu'ils jugent mauvais
la logique de l'admistration trump est
en fait ce qu'on appelle la pression
maximum c'est à dire que la volonté de
l'administration de donald trump a été
de mettre en place toute une série de
contraintes de sanctions qui frappaient
en fait la plupart des secteurs
financier bancaire économique de l'iran
mais également qui touche en fait des
sanctions contre des institutions des
personnalités qui sont particulièrement
symbolique en fait à l'intérieur de la
république islamique et l'iran riposte à
partir du 8 mai 2019 la république
commence à revenir sur certains de ses
engagements et ne collabore plus avec
les yeux a maintenant son programme
nucléaire militaire comme elle l'entend
et comme la situation économique
iranienne est intimement liée à ces
hydrocarbures et à son positionnement
géopolitique l'iran en paie les frais en
quatre ans la crise diplomatique couplée
à la crise qu vides ont conduit à une
inflation dépassant les 40% par an à une
dépréciation de la monnaie iranienne et
un taux de chômage d'environ 10% dans le
pays l'iran doit désormais relancer son
économie barrier restylane avec alain
frau a minima non fait mais là claironne
le crous lac avec les morts admin et
montera vers bastille chodiev avant de
rallier
co-60 liste aujourd'hui et après
plusieurs échecs les négociations
reprennent le 26 juin 2022 le chef de la
diplomatie européenne et le ministre des
affaires étrangères iranien ont annoncé
la reprise des pourparlers indirects
avec les états unis pour restaurer
l'accord historique de 2015 sur le
nucléaire iranien pour l'iran la survie
de l'accord est désormais en jeu et là
de lourdes implications sur toute
l'économie du pays or on a besoin
aujourd'hui en cause de la guerre dans
d'ukraine d'avoir du pétrole notamment
des états unis souhaiterait que l'iran
puisse aussi vous exporter du pétrole
donc un parc d'argent donc ils vont
lever les sanctions et donc l'iran
retrouverez son expansion en économie et
là c'est une possibilité les iraniens
attendent eux gagnent impatience et 10
gardiens de la révolution qui ont des
zones dites politiques écoutent et la
priorité pour la défense de la patrie et
de lire république islamique ce que
l'économie reparte la bombe atomique on
pourra toujours la faire plus tard on
verra bien